[Musique]
démarrer est un habitué
surtout comme ici
18000 dollars par année c'est peut-être
plus de tôt
maintenant on va pas loin
[Musique]
de la pension de la Sécurité de la
vieillesse
Canada
avec au moins
c'est primordial d'augmenter ses
prestations surtout avec la pandémie des
besoins partout dans les provinces et
territoires donc le temps de ce
financement l'eau doit se faire de façon
permanente
prévois une hausse de 10 % de la pension
de la Sécurité de la vieillesse à partir
de 2022 entre-temps les 11 cette semaine
un paiement unique de 500 dollars de
mesures qui vit seulement les 75 ans et
plus
non non lui il est beau
il y a pas que des points Huawei de la
discrimination selon le Bloc québécois
qui propose une augmentation de la
pension de la vieillesse 210 dollars par
mois et des sables pour les années des
65 ans si je te plais si je reste pas
ici
résidence de la maison des
d'avoir un logement abordable alors que
le coût de la vie ne cesse d'augmenter
donc
à la banque alimentaire médical dans
Côte-des-Neiges l'achalandage des 60 ans
et plus apprécié triplette depuis la
pandémie
Radio Canada Montréal